[Music]
hey everyone danny burke here for the
score esports
this week we wanted to take a look at
the richest players in esports
who is absolutely rolling in it but the
thing is
we had a couple of issues with that
question there aren't many publicly
available salaries in esports and so we
decided to go exclusively of
tournament winnings and more importantly
we realized that dota players have won
way more than anyone else in any other
game because
ti prize pools are kind of ridiculous so
we decided to break things up by game
we went down the list of the richest
pros in esports and found the 10
highest earning players from 10
different games
that means each entry features the
player who has won the most money
in their respective game but before we
get into that make sure you are
subscribed to the score esports hit the
subscribe button and the notification
bell so you can get more great videos
just like this one alright so who is
making the big books
let's find out here are the top 10
richest players in
esports by game
off at number 10 we have the highest
earning
fighting game player of all time sonic
fox
to say that sonic fox is a legend within
the fighting game community
would be an understatement to many
they're the single greatest player to
ever touch mortal kombat coming under
the wagon the floss blocked down to
raise the quest
but no offense quarterback thinks up
gets one of the push he's going to give
him
and sonic fox is your evolution
2019 champion
but sonic fox is a champion in more than
just
mortal kombat they've won evo
championships in dragon ball fighters
and injustice
as well as dominated their opponents in
marvel vs capcom infinite
skull girls and plenty of other games
too
goku they reflect on the assist trying
that's gonna be hard and it's right
sonic boss
their 60 first place trophies including
five evo world titles have helped sonic
fox rake in an estimated
six hundred and seventy six thousand
seven hundred and seventy dollars in
earnings
for sonic fox though winning isn't quite
as important as silencing the haters
um guess what i gotta please say is that
i'm gay
black a fairy pretty much everything
republican hates and
the besties first players over here i
guess
thank you so much we're jumping over to
halo now for our number nine entry
with frosty one player does step up to
the player it's going to be apg on font
no please no scoping oh my god
what no no no no no no no no no no
anymore man
is it weird that it wasn't surprised
that he hit that frosty is estimated to
have earned around
686 000 from his tournament wins over
the years
across both halo and call of duty this
makes him the highest earning halo
player of
all time some call of duty fans will
know him for smashing into the scene
during black ops 4.
that's three stipes now for frosty they
keep slow peeking them
and he keeps hitting the shots frosty
frosty gets
four but to everyone else frosty is a
halo
legend winning back-to-back
championships with clg in 2016
and then again with optic in 2017.
we are taking a look at the end of this
game mcqueen recognizing that this one's
over two one there you have
it ladies and gentlemen
optic gaming are your 2017
halo world champions
now he's back on halo again after
joining sentinels in 2020
and looking to take home more trophies
and the dollars that come with them
we're leaping up over two hundred
thousand dollars now for our number
eight entry
loki the highest earning pubg player
ever
if there's a pubg tournament somewhere
you can expect loki to either win it or
die
trying they've used everything they've
got here only the two times
loki lands the headshot does he have the
heels though like he's pushing up loki
picks up the headshot win
3v1 in the end against rb the south
korean superstar
has been with genji for over three years
now winning multiple titles including
the world
championship in 2019. these have helped
him bag an
estimated 890 840 dollars in tournament
winning so far
and he's showing no signs of stopping
grenade goes off to the side
not going to connect with anyone now and
it's just about trying to figure out
exactly where doya is
the step up comes through and it's going
to be navi taking the
out but the real story here is
your 2019 pgc champions
gen g having made more than 900
000 in his starcraft career it's no
wonder that cyril comes in
at number seven cyril is a starcraft
prodigy and one of the most exciting
non-korean players in the game's
history in 2018 he became the first
foreigner to ever win a wcs
global finals and i don't think there's
any solution here for stats
he's going to commit cereal overwhelming
the airplane of stats
and that is it
cerro comes from a small farming village
in finland but despite his unlikely
beginnings
he has decimated just about every
starcraft opponent he's played against
but daryl says not today is gonna kite
backwards the zealots are gone
the archives are gone we've got a
champion of wcs austin
it's daryl surprise surprise the best
player wins it again
cerro's winnings are an estimated 912
thousand dollars to date and although
the pandemic 4 starcraft tournaments
online
cyril is quite happy to catch his checks
from home the disruptor is going to try
and fire and they used a shot
but it wasn't enough sterile takes the
game so
abruptly coming in at number six
is our unlikeliest entry who also
happens to be our first
million dollar player it's feg the
richest shadowverse player
ever although he entered the 2018
shadowverse grand prix as an
underdog he swept the competition to
take home the 1
million dollar grand prize
i'm so sorry wow
what a series though unbelievable play
from
both players in this finals
fake's gonna take it home what's crazy
is that this
single victory accounted for most of his
earnings and catapulted him
onto this list his total earnings stand
up one million and
three thousand dollars but trust us he's
far
from the richest player on this list you
can call our number five entry toxic but
chrome 6 only cares about
one thing winning at all costs
let him know that is a huge performance
from six
crim6 is arguably the call of duty goat
and given the game's prize pools it's
not surprising to see that he's taken
home
some serious stacks in his day trim six
and eggs have the front unlocked tp
watching the point
one go way down is gonna do it that is
that
complexity takes out impact and they are
crowned
the winners of mlg anaheim crimson
has won an estimated 1 million 190
000 from tournaments over the years now
that's partly due to him winning a lot
of them
but also because he's been competing for
almost a
decade at this point across every
iteration of call of duty
[Applause]
consented 247 a piece who's gonna get it
the time to take him is still
when he parted ways with optic in 2019
some doubted that he could remain at the
top
but crim proved them wrong with yet
another world championship win
and the money that comes with it can
they win it the flood's going to be on
through
shock to the smokesburg criminal he's
been massive
in this series there's the final kill
dallas empire for your 2020
call of duty league champions crim6
now undisputedly the greatest
call of duty player of all time
coming in at number four is the richest
league of legends player of
all time with 1.2 million dollars
in tournament winnings it's none other
than the unkillable demon king himself
faker under turrets wolf coming in
double six they get the flash from
knocking faker comes in he's got the old
he's got the kill
after bursting onto the scene in 2013 it
didn't take long for faker to become the
undisputed goat of league of legends
he's won nine domestic titles two msi's
and is one of only two players to win
three world championships in league's
history
his many tournaments have earned him an
estimated one million
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
and of course
we're contractually obliged to show you
this clip before i think he's at the bed
oh baker maybe a trouble your death mark
tries to clean it up for ryu oh look at
the class look at the moves
faker what was that now it's likely that
faker is
even richer when you take salary and
sponsorship deals into account i mean
this guy is doing doritos commercials in
china
but none of those numbers are public
which means faker is gonna have to win
worlds again to
really climb up this list at just 24
years old though time is definitely on
his side
do they have the damage though cuz
actually in that back line and faker
stays alive for the entire time
all the other carries on the side i fear
her x do go down
really nice stopwatch though from joseph
staying alive this is such a close fight
and banker's gonna take it down in the
end with a double kill
as t1 will pick up the ace leaping up
hundreds of thousands of dollars now and
taking us into our top
three we have the wealthiest cs go
player in the game
dupree now they're gonna try and double
push him they don't have a kid currently
picked up that's a big problem he gets
another kill
taken down again and again and again
capri
winning it for restaurants dupreeh has
been one of csgo's best for years and is
one of only six players to have attended
every single major and he hasn't just
attended all of them
duprey along with his astralis teammates
have won more cs go majors than
anyone else in the game according to
esports earnings dupree has made
18999 156 dollars and
seven cents putting him just a couple of
thousand bucks over his teammates
zip x and device but all of astralis
core members can rest
easy knowing that basically no one else
in cs go can even come
close to their prize winnings
[Applause]
leaping us up to 3 million we have the
richest fortnight player of
all time and probably one of the richest
kids on the planet
booga but ladies and gentlemen there's
no way
anyone beats him your fortnite world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
champion
shot to success faster than most pros
can ever dream of
he played his first big event in 2018 a
squad's event hosted in a microsoft
store where he took home a share of 5
000
but by the following year that would
look like pennies
booga won the fortnight world
championship taking home
three million dollars and blasting his
total earnings
to 3.1 million
still alive shots going down can't
connect with that one what builds left
the final moments of fortnite oh my gosh
that win helped booga catapult to fame
and made him one of the richest esports
players of
all time at least one of the richest
esports players who doesn't play
dota that is taking the number one spot
on our list
is the big daddy himself no tailor
no-tell is the richest dota player of
all time
with 6.9 million dollars to his name
but his og teammates aren't too far
behind in fact the five
richest esports players of all time are
the five members of og that won
back-to-back ti's in 2018 and 2019
dota players dominate any list of the
highest earning pros in esports
mainly due to the internationals prize
pools dwarfing
every other game ti9 boasted a
staggering
34 million dollars for its prize pool
even coming in fifth made you an instant
millionaire
hell even players who haven't won ti
are loaded artesi is the 23rd richest
esports player of all time according to
esports earnings
making him richer than every non-dota
player aside from booger
and he's never won t.i or a valve major
as for no tail well cashing the biggest
check in esports
twice as well as plenty of earnings from
other tournaments
means that he has more than enough cash
to splash on things like his new mansion
in portugal
i'm spending one and a half on we're
also giving myself another 300k to work
with so
up to 1.8 1.8 million yeah
that's a lot of money it's a good chunk
it's a good chunk yeah
all right guys there you go were any of
those surprises people that you didn't
expect to be on there
do you want to see more rich or money
based videos from us
in the future let us know thanks for
watching and i'll see you all
in the next one have you seen dope yet
no
just protect me
[Music]
ah he took the whole thing with him
that's why we play support
because when it matters we cannot count
on you